j'ai mangé le lundi le mardi le mercredi
le vendredi ça m'amuse mon fils me fais
goûter bio je me dis que de préférence
et les jeunes qui viennent pour qu'on
fait moins du que je suis pas moi
terrible mais quand même
baho économique le big mac
ce gros sandwich américain à la viande
on passe d'envahir le monde comme le
coca cola c'est le fleuron du fast food
en français nourriture rapide 100
secondes pour faire cuire une tranche de
steaks hachés congelés
55 secondes pour toaster et sausset une
sonnerie rythmant chaque opération
quelques gestes pour la salade les
oignons les cornichons le fromage en
deux minutes exactement le client est
servi les études de marché donnait le
big mac et ses frères perdant en france
pays de la gastronomie
or le chiffre d'affaires de la filiale
française a progressé de 96 % en un an
je ne préférais pas moi j'ai un petit
repas chauds ailleurs tranquillement non
parce que dans les cafés c'est très cher
c'est long
ici c'est plus complet c'est plus sympa
donc la piste d'un restaurant un café il
ya beaucoup de monde ya beaucoup de
bruit réussissent assez tranquille on
est indépendant on n'a pas de service à
donner mais quand j'ai créé après le
garçon une fois qu'on est servi tout dix
mois on mange il ya le style du
d'amérique un petit peu oui
nostalgie nostalgie 15 milliards de
hamburg heurts ont déjà été mangés dans
les 5000 restaurants de la chaîne et à
wall street l'action du hamburger ne
fait que monter des produits
industrialisés et donc on n'a pas refait
contrôle de chacun des éléments qui
rendent à la composition des produits et
donc n'importe qui qui va dans n'importe
quel restaurant mcdonald's n'importe où
dans le monde aura toujours le même
produit et ça c'est un élément
effectivement du succès de toute manière
et pourquoi pas un produit adapté à la
france
celui-ci marche en france pourtant
choisir un autre pour les restaurateurs
français de fast food
les débuts sont difficiles un tiers
d'entre eux à peine ouverts ont déjà dû
fermer artisans souvent promu bricoleur
ce n'était pas suffisant
quant aux rescapés ils cherchent leur
créneau
ces américains ont des arguments à faire
valoir au niveau technique sans
réalisation et nous nous essayons d'axer
nos politiques vers le goût le goût
français au niveau du pain les veaux des
sauces au niveau de la viande
en attendant le géant américain a déjà
transporté à paris son école de hamburg
oncologie pour former ses premiers
rejetons
vous avez découvert travail important ce
monde à servir entre eux ce qui vous
rend heureux c'est la courtoisie tout
marche
[Musique]